They say when the rider burns you, he burns your soul.
Hey YouTubers, it's Charlie. So we got Robbie Reyes footage of the actual car
in Ghost Rider form. It looks like he's just gonna make everybody go splat.
So let's break it down.
So the whole idea here is they're just showing you what the car is going to look like most of the time.
I can't even imagine how expensive it would be
to have the whole thing engulfed in flames constantly
while it was on screen, all the time.
So from a practical perspective, I think what they've done
is they've found a fun way to
like something that's really cool on screen, without completely depleting their budget.
That'd be a dope way to end any TV show. You have one CG character
that's so expensive to do, that you can only do the show for a couple of episodes
so you're like: "Okay, what we're gonna do is we're gonna have that
CG character go around and kill all of the other characters."
So that the show's over.
But the thing here
I think they're doing this the right way too, is they're
not having the Ghost Rider character speak.
You just see him, you hear other characters talking about him,
"They say when the rider burns you, he burns your soul."
The car itself has some different abilities when he is in Ghost Rider form.
When he is fully flame-on Ghost Rider, he can actually
walk right through it, as if it's nothing. He can pilot it remotely,
and if he's not standing right next to the car, he can actually
teleport inside of it. So he doesn't have to open the door to get inside,
He can will himself inside of the car.
But that's only when he's in Ghost Rider form,
not when he's walking around as normal Robbie Reyes.
So, I don't know how they're going to deal with that on the show,
There's actually a couple of easy ways for them to film stuff like that
But the car itself is a normal car
So it drives around like a normal car would,
when he's not Ghost Rider.
But if you read any of the Ghost Rider comics or if you've seen any of the Ghost Rider movies,
You know that when Johnny Blaze is riding around on his motorcycle
when he's Ghost rider, it gains all these extra abilities
that normal motorcycles don't have.
So, just expect them to have some fun with some really crazy, WTF action set pieces with
the car. Which I think is a nice addition. There haven't been a lot of vehicle stunts
since the first couple of seasons of Agents of S.H.I.E.L.D.
They've done some motorcycle work, they had a little fun with the cloaking device on
Quinjets, but I think the car is gonna be a little bit more fun to actually watch week to week.
I've already talked a little bit about Robbie Reyes' backstory in the comics, but he basically
merges with this other spirit. It's not quite the same thing as Johnny Blaze, it's not a biblical spirit of
Vengence. We don;t know if he has all of the same abilities as the Johnny Blaze Ghost Rider.
Like the penance stare, or if he can manifest chains and things from his mouth, or
if he can discharge hellfire from guns.
When Johnny Blaze uses a gun, it can discharge magical fire.
He's still going to be really powerful no matter what but I think we'll get a good
idea for how powerful in the first couple of episodes. There will be some limits
but, just for an example, in the comics, Doctor Strange says that Johnny Blaze, when he's in Ghost Rider form,
is more powerful than the version of Hulk during Planet Hulk and World War Hulk.
Like the Gladiator Hulk persona, which is way crazier than normal hulk
So basically Ghost ride, for all intents and purposes,
on Agents of S.H.I.E.L.D., is kind of like a game changer character
but because of who he is, because of the Ghost Rider persona,
he's kind of a wild card, so you can imagine how S.H.I.E.L.D.'s going to react to that
It's gonna be a lot of fun watching them trying to get him on the team.
But even though they're continuing to do Inhumans stuff, they did tease that they would be doing
Royal Family -like deep, deep cuts from the Inhumans comics, I don't think they're gonna tie Ghost Rider to
any of that stuff. I think they'll be relatively true to the comics
because they said part of the idea in doing Ghost Rider this season is because they're doing more mystical
Doctor Strange things in the movies, they're moving into new territory in the MCU.
They wanted to follow suit on the TV show. So they're like okay, Ghost Rider
is a really fun visual way to push into the magical realm, that we can totally do on TV.
Because there is no way that they're gonna make another Ghost Rider movie
anytime soon. But for those of you asking, there is a chance that Ghost Rider could totally appear in the movies eventually.
but I would expect it to be relatively small, and if he does go somewhere else in the MCU,
I really think it's going to be on the Netflix shows. That would be a lot of fun. Just have
him show up in the Punisher series, Maybe in Iron Fist's series at a certain point, maybe the second season of
Iron Fist, because they're pretty much done filming that show.
In fact, one of the cast members from Iron Fist, who plays Colleen Wing, is a Sand Snake on Game of Thrones
she just went back to Belfast. So I think they're pretty much done filming most of Iron Fist
series. But there will probably be more news about that this year after Luke Cage drops.
Which is actually in a couple of weeks! Agents of S.H.I.E.L.D. is coming back on the 20th, Luke Cage is
coming back the week after that. So it's like back-to-back Marvel TV shows dropping
it's gonna be a lot of fun. So be sure to subscribe to get all of those videos,
I'll be doing videos for Agents of S.H.I.E.L.D. and for Luke Cage
it'll be a little bit different for Luke Cage, because it's all dropping at once
so the Luke Cage stuff will post a little bit more like when i was doing Daredevil season 2 earlier this year
where it's like one video every couple days. And the people that have seen it so far say it is like the best
Marvel Netflix series so far. I cannot wait to see all this stuff.
So, next video will be Spider-Man Homecoming, they'll be posting more behind the scenes stuff,
There's some interesting differences in the way they're doing MoCap for Spider-Man Homecoming
it's evolved a little bit since they've done CIvil War.
So a whole bunch of really cool Behind the Scenes Spider-Man stuff coming soon.
While you guys wait for that to post, you can click here for Avengers Infinity War BTS
And you can click here for the last big Luke Cage trailer again.
Thank you so much for watching, everybody, lets high-five, Sweet Christmas! stuff coming back real soon!